Last time I googled myself...
...was pretty much the last time I googled myself...
...because I don't do it anymore...
...because it's really bad.
Like, don't do it.
Don't google yourself, ever.
People have a lot of opinions on my butt.
First time I met a super fan.
I think the first time was in Barneys.
That was when it was like, super-duper fan,...
...when the elevator doors opened and then someone was just like, "Khaleesi!"
And then the doors closed, and then I left, so that was kind of okay.
The first time I met Jason Momoa was in a hotel lobby in Belfast.
And I walk in and I'm like, exhausted and I have my bags and I'm really tired...
...and we just, it was really late at night and I walked in...
...and from the other side of this enormous lobby I hear, "Wifey!"
And this huge Hawaiian man comes bounding over to me,...
...picks me up and genuinely gets me in like, a rugby tackle to the floor.
It was only when he picked me back up and kinda dusted me off...
...and I was like, "Who are you?"